hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
unique mystery and horror movie called
countdown there's a bonus trivia at the
end of the video so make sure to watch
until the end the movie starts with a
group of teenagers being at a party they
discuss an application that contains a
diet program
then one of them wants to join the
program by searching the application on
her cell phone but instead she finds
another application called countdown the
app seems to be able to predict how much
time is left for the user to live
they are curious about the ridiculous
application and she invites the others
to download the app just for fun
they agree that the person closest to
the time of death has to finish all the
drinks on the table
they also simultaneously download the
application and sure enough the
application immediately shows the time
of their respective deaths when everyone
gets a long time to die it's different
for a woman named courtney she only has
three hours left to die obviously she
has to finish all the drinks there
they also explain to evan about the game
seeing his girlfriend about to be
overwhelmed evan helps her finish the
drinks
later evan wants to drive courtney home
but she finds out that her boyfriend is
drunk telling him it's unsafe to drive
in the end she decides to walk alone on
the way she suddenly gets a notification
from the application that she has broken
the user agreement which reduces her
time to seven minutes until death
she frantically runs to her house and
tries to turn off her cell phone
feeling safe she is suddenly attacked by
an unseen entity and killed as her timer
reaches zero
at the same time evan crashes because
he's drunk and a tree branch goes right
through where courtney would have sat
indicating that she must remain dead
according to the timer then the scene
switches to a hospital there is a woman
named quinn who is an intern at the
hospital where evan is admitted she is
very passionate about doing her job as a
nurse
at one time she sees a warning tape that
has been cut off at the door of a room
being renovated then she tries to check
into the room and she meets evan sitting
by the window he told her that he is
worried because of the app he has
downloaded and also tells what happened
to his girlfriend
it is as if the app is real for him
quinn calms him by saying that maybe it
was just a coincidence
shortly after they are warned by the
senior nurse because they have entered a
prohibited area she is taken to another
room and it turns out that her friends
surprise her that now she is officially
a nurse at the hospital while eating she
tells the story about evan who has a
strange application
her friends certainly become curious and
download the application straight away
they are happy because they still get a
long time in the application when she
wants to go home quinn gets a message
from an unknown telling her to download
the app
out of curiosity she also downloads the
application and unfortunately she only
gets less than three days but she still
doesn't care about it returning home she
remembers her mother who had died before
she and her younger sister jordan have
not been close since their mother died
then her father invites her to visit her
mother's grave on saturday she naturally
accepts the invitation
the next day evan looked very nervous
and worried because he is about to have
his surgery and he only has three
minutes left according to the
application
he eventually believes in the
application and skips his surgery
because he states that he will die when
the operation coincided with the time in
his application
then he receives a message informing
that he has broken the user agreement he
sees a figure dressed in black behind
him through the glass
he panics and tries to run away but
unfortunately he is killed by a demonic
version of courtney later quinn gets the
news that a patient named evan has died
in an accident they think he jumped to
commit suicide she then remembers the
time on evan's cell phone
she immediately checks whether the time
was up
she is horrified when the timing really
matched evan's death
she checks her remaining time knowing
that her time will end on saturday when
that day she has an appointment with her
family to visit her mother's grave she
decides to cancel the appointment
because that's when bad things will
happen to her again she receives a
similar message as courtney and evan
not long after
she is ordered to accompany the
examination
she seems unfocused on her work
dr sullivan tries to calm her down but
unexpectedly she is sexually abused by
the doctor
fortunately she manages to escape and
wants to report the incident to her
senior but her effort fails when dr
sullivan distracts her senior
that night she looks for a way to remove
the app but apparently the app can't be
uninstalled
she then researches for news related to
the death caused by the application
surprisingly she learns the news about
courtney's death exactly the same as
what evan has told her before
soon she goes to a cell phone store and
she wants to buy a new cell phone
including the new number hoping she
doesn't have the app anymore
at first she is happy because she
doesn't have the app on her new cell
phone but after a while the application
installed itself
the seller derek is also confused about
it causing the other visitors to ask
about the application that was shown by
quinn
in her car she checks that she has 21
hours remaining and then she sees the
black figure behind her car
after being attacked by a demonic figure
she encounters matt whose countdown
states he will die a few hours before
her
in the end they share stories about the
events experienced by each other they
decide to meet the priest who works at
quinn's place they tell about its
applications related to demons and evil
spirits
unfortunately the priest tells them to
meet someone else who understands more
about it before they meet the person
quinn is called by her senior and learns
that dr sullivan has tricked the senior
nurse into thinking that she sexually
harassed him as a result she is
suspended from her job at the same time
matt is attacked by the entity taking
the form of his deceased brother in the
toilet later they go to the church and
meet father john there they tell the
devil in the app as if it is always
following them the priest says that what
happened to them is the same as the
story he has read before telling them
that the death caused by the app is not
natural but the work of a demon named
ozin according to him the disturbance
they have experienced is a modern
version of the old story he has read
quinn suddenly has an idea to hack the
app they go to see derek hoping he can
help to hack the countdown
by giving him money he wants to do it he
eventually manages to hack the app by
adding some time into it quinn is
surprised when she finds her sister's
name is on the application server
indicating that her sister already
downloaded it she also asks him to add
some time for her sister they happily
return to the house and sleep together
in the middle of the night unfortunately
the countdown automatically reverts to
its original times
they also check on jordan and she also
experiences the same thing they go back
to the church asking father john what to
do next he theorizes that the devil is
the source of lies the curse can be
broken by proving the devil's lie if
someone dies before their countdown ends
or lives after then they plan to
withstand the demon's attack with a
ritual of protection they know that matt
has only two minutes left which means he
will be the first to be targeted by the
devil they make a circle and stay inside
sure enough the devil comes and matt is
lured out by the devil taking the form
of his younger brother he is hit by a
car as his time reaches zero because
jordan was injured in the incident she's
taken to the hospital by quinn where she
learns dr sullivan also harasses other
nurses he takes care of jordan until she
recovers the girls admit each other's
mistakes and finally they make up
at that time quinn has another idea to
stop the devil
she pretends to flirt with dr sullivan
in his room and asks him to meet in a
private place
when he gets there quinn suddenly
attacks him but he is always saved by
the devil who doesn't want her to kill
dr sullivan the devil prepares to kill
jordan first in the middle of the fight
it takes the form of her mother who was
already dead but quinn is able to
overdose on drugs sacrificing herself
the devil is gone and jordan notices
quinn has written something on her arm
narcan
she revives her with the narcan and the
girls succeed as the countdown timer
stop
when she visits her mother's grave quinn
hears news about sullivan's arrest after
more nurses came forward but
unexpectedly she discovers an update of
the app countdown 2.0 has downloaded
itself onto her phone
there is a fact that the application
actually exists in the real world
similarly called countdown if you are
curious about it you can try to download
it just for fun subscribe to watch more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching
[Music]